no tengo idea de por qué habla con ustedes sobre una
capa y una máscara y novecientos de
vente parábolas hubo un famoso único
balance de Macan solamente sobre mí ahora
cualquier cristal sí un bloque en su lugar
primero soy kyra habla usted sabe significar hombre
Danielle para soleado que viste  irani
puritanical and Iran just animate esta
and met oriental nombres son muy
poderosas Danielle a tsunami poderoso lenguaje
que significa Esperanza
pero kapa haka far sunny significant sin
and my desear blood con ustedes sobre
algunos a story a story nothing
wash over van cuando estamos hablando
super corporal  noble que estudia
alfiler de madera lo siento Néstor histo y Esther
tiene 200 trans para impulsar la historia
no puede poner un monstruo RNs el quejarse
ver un provisional pero y baila no
la media novecientos cierto tiempo en
división dos setenta lingua cabo decir
que era una cierva en los  tribunales no muy
pronto un estado de persona indeleble papá
oh no se presiona otorgar el medio
siento tan gentil minera  ls into the
rentals say asado in glass seat has
rapid ascent ray hombres mujeres Y oil
and yes I was a Dementor hombres y
hombres y tambien mujeres y mujeres pero
quiero hablar con ustedes abran algo que
pasa Casio chant as annuals address sub
Yankee Hitler to moon  a spur to the
language a corporal su nombre era Eric
Harrison el dijo a Hitler particular
person as common super hablas en serio
primero
I used the Bianca con miedo y disgusto
Rose interesante intra sentimiento es
elemento de apoyo L Erik Anderson fueron
quienes lo hacen es un  proporción
tan alegre como la desesperación Silverhawks
bounnam misterio habla con ustedes abran
propia Tama y psicológicamente soy una
sincronía Adela interacción es SOS
cuando los movimientos cuerpo dicen
coordinación Immelt ania Minton sí muy
pronto
señal la empatía a través de simpatía una
participación entusiasta y cuando eres
monstruo Alice  propietario medium pero antes
que monster on this as a video 0 hablar
con usted
so playing like this the que esta pasando
estamos h  ablando super synchrony Adeline
traxion acustica who study tener un 4k
y en su mano de esta chica es
simultanea a el dueno de este chick
who I am pero antes que nos vemos as a
video curator less on a hand-blown
imagine a musket an emotion pero  para
una que para tener control there's the
pero una de villiers return la carrera
see another stone dilemma Nova's están
de él para ver lo que nosotros vamos a
ver metafórico Amanda blond the newest
and if Renta vamos a ver la video
you know anuncia commodities in in
espanol en la tienda de las bolas huh
[Risas]
bounnam in cata conversación guru pal
siempre on macho alpha even ember alpha
aqui
I own natural alpha and it's the Pais
assum a alpha in este mundo in macho
alpha NS a context aunque I own Umbra
alpha  mira lo que reuniste
como un video pero lo desplazó un
Paragon sin talento una pregunta vamos a
ver ese video en 4k sn2 manos pnpn
circus Umbra alpha NS el video grande
una personas  goostin n Tracy copyin
los restos de l'autre he in synchrony
deinteraction Vienna in different form as
if young Students we are planes for a
football aqui tenemos Michael Owen
jeopardy on goal el estaba jugando al pobre
Liverpool a can he do at goal and
Manchester  United he he no podemos ver
SI un maharaja atrás y esta haciendo
esto esto es taco P&O los que esto de
jugar favorito again so significant a is
in cha verdadero
al igual que todos de mas
pronita in traction Vienna in defender
for mass consumer
look mo stylist  gear hablar con ustedes
sobre discurso de política chilena
okay justo okuru in Iqbal try so antis
the elecciones and go spin this is
theater in este video nuestra in forte
esto lament and Panera a cast solamente
vamos a ver los movimientos corporal is
the Sun synchronous Otto in  kanji
antimension vamos a bailar video
Mitchell virtualmente no debe illa por
elderman Cinco or Allah so hysterical
second a lingua navien in Nome elevenses
Mitc  hell de Chile you no debe Villa
by elderman Cinco or Allah or ah so
hysterical second Domingo en avión yo me lavenza
prefer oh no a black mass of the
policy children or because no Kirika
made important and this the security
of each Widow and El Pais willya  Paragon
town let's on a curry Kunta some a
mustiness príncipe cargo well know it
reconozca un swing Kara Tristan no Feliz
catalizador y baila no se desespere
esperamos para encontrar esta Kara por
ejemplo
non funeral say cerca de las personas
con quien no no stammers Komodos and  en
Supermercado i algunos casos caput apri
decir señal tan pronto como seas malo
oh no los restos pueden transmitir los
verdaderos
intenciones como emos eunice de las
personas debe ser importante los restos caballero
poner más importante justicia
puddin en Gani nuestro auto versus
masacre ir tener  un amigo inclusivo
puddinin' ganyan la baie de l'autre
política internacional y bailes de alce
me pagaron entrar y qué monstruo Alison
vide  o sí al video tinnitus partes de
Fanta pyramid una parte está saturada a Bill
Clinton dice caminando el propio
funeral y mientras que está caminando
él está durmiendo kannan en el registro su
lado es el hermano yo y o un año se
arrepintió anata
km cámara al igual que la  guerra bandulu he
to arrepentirse el quiere cambia su estado the
animal
Loki is off with the tratar Olympia like
imagine areas up abajo de sus ojos a tan
pronto has to the era Pentimento despues
en este video segunda parte los vamos a
per mil novecientos au chante uno  de
matrimonio the Cardozo Deanna in nos
vamos a ver lo mismo esto con principal
principal Carlos Isuzu esto the era
Pentimento
[Music]
you
hola mi amor como tu sientes idea huh I
see to be on di muy buena come over to
dia quanto  base nos vemos a ver esto
que esto para nós temos cuenta de lo que
estamos viendo character person estes
entiendo
eww key decir you know soy el primero
person Aikido in contrast the histone no
pero kiddin sabe lo  que yo encuentro un
LPM arabesco eres como el video
cocaina country pronto respuesta de esta
pregunta con la verdadera cerca Deanna I
cuatro opciones todas las opciones and
character oh yeah the silver squall and
yeah when I can sunset on a futon we
must set the laws  del país que era
potrancas
hasta ahora Tyrone Yenta puddin bien un río
que escalamos de número Quatro en
todo el personal fuera y poniendo dónde están
ya gracias en Atlanta sí gemela Susi
comenzó ronda en Cesarea Auto TED
talk pobre [ __ ]
Tobiah Darla's ma me gustaría  decir una
estafa Fidelio a las personas otra vez de
lengua corporal los nuestro
tiempo Esparza Energia in el ambiente
lebron entrevista en nuestras relaciones
muchas gracias por su charm a más
gracias importante por mirar my Festus
[Aplausos]